i don't want to dwell on kova that often
but i think every now and again we just
got to show these little blip moments
where you just see that they just keep
moving on this stuff right so you can
live your life you can ignore all of it
but there is this machine version of it
that's just passing through that's
convincing people that they still have
to listen to these people and do all
this stuff and and be scared and afraid
and all of that this is covid response
coordinator ashish ja
saying the goal is not to get back to
normal but something else perhaps
i've heard secretary cardona say this
over and over again you know people do
talk about going back to normal and i've
heard mr secretary uh say you know
normal wasn't working out so well
forever for some people and so the goal
in my mind is not to go back to normal
the goal is to build a very different
new normal that has equity much more at
the heart of it
yeah well then every now and again they
tell you the quiet part right uh no more
old world i thought that old world was
pretty good you remember that old world
it was a hell of a lot better than this
yeah well they want a new world and they
want equity to be part of it when you
say you want equity in health that is
the most anti-i would say hippocratic oh
thing that you could possibly say
because what you're saying is we want
equity now that means that everyone
based on their because these people love
skin color and gender and sexuality
everyone across the board will get the
same amount of covet and we'll have the
same amount of deaths and all that stuff
you know what that means basically uh it
means that what they want in essence is
more dead white people that really is
the end result of what they want i have
no doubt media matters is going to clip
this and post it but that is what they
want when they say want equity in health
care uh and by the way that's not even
an exaggeration because we know that
cities in the united states i believe
seattle did it and a couple others were
giving
vaccines based on skin color right and
eventually they'll do it based on
sexuality and everything else whether
the vaccines work or not is a moot point
but you this is them ushering in their
great reset it's ushering in their new
world i just don't want anything to do
with it i got one more on factory
because i saw this this morning um and
it's a it's a side-by-side of fouchy on
how he decides what we should be doing
when it comes to certain things like
hydro uh hcq
versus uh when it comes to vaccines i
mean this is really extraordinary
watches
when i do see
a randomized placebo-controlled trial
that looks at any aspect of
hydroxychloroquine either early study
middle study or late if that randomized
placebo-controlled trial shows efficacy
i would be the first one to admit it and
to promote it so i just have to go with
the data i don't have any horse in the
game one way or the other it hasn't been
proven in a clinical trial because we
don't have
time to do a clinical trial because we
need to get the vaccine out now
that second video that you saw there
that's from a day or two ago so do you
see that what he just did there when it
was hcq and people were saying hey this
might work
this might prevent covid or might lessen
the symptoms he needed way more data
guys we need studies we need data early
studies late studies you got to throw me
something give me some papers on the
desk to look at
now
that it's oh maybe it'll be annual
vaccines for you guys we gotta rush this
[ __ ] out people we can't look at the
data we don't have time for paper i
could get a paper cut
they are just absolutely awful i i just
cannot believe that anyone thinks that
anthony fauci the highest paid person in
the federal government 420
000 a year on top of i think he's going
to make that salary continually while he
retires and god knows how much money
he's made through all of the vaccine
stuff and everything else and all of the
shady deals and what information he gave
to people related to drug companies like
he just reeks of all of those things i
am the science no i i am the lies that's
what he really is anyway i just wanted
to get through a little bit of that
let's not freak out about covid uh oh
and the white house also has this new
monkey pox advisor that actually i'm
pretty sure is spreading monkey pox but
that's a whole other story